네 안녕하세요 빌 사람입니다 제가
오늘은 좀 특별한 현장에 와 있는데
굉장히 좀
역사가 기쁜 빌딩 현장이에요 그래서이
빌딩 같은 경우에는
현대 건축의 거장인 두 분이 계세요
첫 번째 분이 이제 김수금 건축가
님이시고 두 번째가이 건물을 설계한
김중호 건축가님이라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다
[음악]
이 건물 같은 경우에는
1965년도에 설계를 했어요
휴전이 1953년도에 했잖아요 한
12년 정도 이후에 이제 설계를 한
건데 그때 당시에 정말 제가 봤을
때는 파격적으로 설계 디자인을 한
것으로 좀 보여집니다 그리고 되게
신기한게 다 이제 곡선으로 되어
있어요 그래서 여기 지금 발코니도
보면은 좀 되게 신기해요
뭔가 그 스페인에서 본듯한 그런
건축물 같고 이쪽으로 좀 오시면 지금
이쪽에 발코니도 이렇게 곡선으로 돼
있습니다 건물 전체적으로 좀 이렇게
곡선이 많고 좀 이렇게 직각이나
저희가 일반적으로 생각하는 그런 건물
모양이 아니에요 그래서 건물 외관
자체가 좀 일반적으로 우리가
봤던 그런 건물들이랑 좀 많이 달라요
많이 다르고 그때 당시 그러니까
1965년도에 설계한 것으로는 진짜
믿기지 않을 정도로
특별하고 뭔가 예술 작품 같은 어
그런 건물이라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다 그래서 아내가 굉장히 좀
궁금하긴 한데 안에 들어가서 한번 좀
보도록 하시죠
여기 이제 안에 들어왔는데 여기는
일단 지금 디자인 회사 사옥으로 좀
쓰고 있어서 여기도 이렇게 다
곡선이 많아요 이쪽도 그렇고 이렇게
저희가 일반적으로 보는 그런 건물
모습이랑은 내부 모습도 좀 다릅니다
아 이렇게 돼 있구나
[박수]
여기도 이렇게
[음악]
그래서 이쪽에 이제 다 외벽이 노출
콘크리트인데 이렇게 좀 창을 많이
뒀습니다
[음악]
어 그래서 저희가 지금
밑에서 봤던
발코니 앞에 나와 있는데
와 이거
그때 당시 어떻게 이렇게 살아도
되겠지 그 한
5년 전 6년 전인가 그때 이제
스페인
갔을 때 이렇게 가우디 건축물도 좀
보고 했는데
진짜 약간 그 느낌이 약간 있어요
1965년도에 이런 건물을
뭔가 설계했다는 걸 좀 굉장히 좀
높게 평가합니다
와 여기가
조망이 되게 좋네요
여기서 이제 해가 뜨거든요
햇빛이 제일 잘 들어오는 위치에 있고
사실 그때 당시에 건물은 저희가 보는
그 퇴계로의 낡은 건물이 대부분인데
우리가 잘 몰라서 그런지 그때
당시에는 진짜 엄청난 일이었습니다
[음악]
네
정말 그 인터넷에서만 보던 그 건물의
현장에서 좀 보니까
정말
놀랬습니다
놀랬고 그 60년대 좀 이렇게 놀라운
건축물을 설계하신 그 김중호
건축가님이 되게 좀 존경스럽고 그리고
좀 이렇게 우리나라도 좀 이런
건축가님들이 좀 많이 나왔으면
좋겠습니다
[음악]
건축이라는 것은 인간하고 가장 밀접한
거 아니겠어요 사람이 집 속에서
태어나고 또 집 속에서 살고 또
집에서
운명한다 말이에요
그러니까 훌륭한 건축물이라는 것은 딴
것이 아니고
인간에게 보금자리로서의
역할을 제대로 해줘야 된다
하는 기능적인 면하고 또 봤을 때
즐거움을 줄 수 있는 하여튼 아름다운
거야 된다
하는 것이 원칙이 아니겠어요